if we have self-learning robots is it a
possibility that they're going to become
smarter than us and then view us as a
hindrance
i don't think it would be hard michaela
for robots to be smarter than us we're a
fairly dumb species
um whether we'll become the slaves of
them is a really interesting one i think
it's
a technological issue which
quite frankly is kind of
beyond me i'm not a technologist the
idea it's an ongoing debate amongst
the hardcore scientists who study ai of
whether
we can essentially
by giving uh
ai's giving robots giving smart machines
the ability to think whether they can
out think us and so i i
you know philosophically of course it's
a very sexy idea it's been the um
subject of many different science
fiction writers the idea of right from
the 19th century in fact even before the
19th century the idea of us creating
machines frankensteins which come to
rule us
so philosophically it's fascinating i
think it would be an appropriate end to
our species i think we
get what we deserve but
in technological terms i'm not quite
sure i just don't
i don't understand that the the
the increase the intricacies of the
debate in terms of
whether or not
we can build machines which then go on
to think for themselves and then think
beyond us if we do then we are the
footnote as somebody famously said they
are our last invention uh so it's it's
impossible to say and uh for me at least
and i think the scientific community is
very divided and when you talk to
serious scientists rather than
people who just seek headlines
most of them will say well we really
really don't know it it's such a
complicated subject and perhaps
a subject which will surprise us because
uh we'll only know when we know so as i
said you know maybe you're maybe you're
an i am maybe i'm an ai
i'll only know when we know
and maybe we'll never know and that will
be the
interesting narrative that will get
ruled by ais and we won't even know
maybe we already are
well that's a horrifying
well i don't know aren't you happy you
seem quite a cheerful person maybe it's
it wouldn't bother me in the world today
if ais are ruling they're not doing a
bad job they could do a lot worse i'm
sure i don't know i just had to move
from canada i wasn't very happy by how
that was being run but maybe it needs
more ai oh you're where are you now i'm
in nashville tennessee so you went from
canada to nashville yeah isn't that
going from the
frying pan to the fire
oh it depends what you identify the fire
as
okay
okay so
ai
it's it so it's in the military now
you know they're using smart machines to
track faces and everything and then each
side has their own ai
do you think
so it's already implemented in some
areas do you think when it gets
implemented in factories this is going
to be an issue for factory workers or
people who have more automated jobs
yeah that's an interesting question it's
already being implemented i mean it's
when people talk about new tech when
people talk about the internet when
people talk about the next generation
technology some people use the term now
web 3 as the next chapter after web 2.0
it's everywhere it's ubiquitous so
whenever you're talking about tech or
big tech or big tech companies you're
talking about ai so amazon for example
is essentially an ai company google is
an ai company facebook is a good ai
company even apple
is an ai company focusing on hardware so
it's already in factories if you have
the ill fortune of working in an amazon
factory you're being watched all the
time by smart machines
your ability or inability on the shop
floor is being watched and increasingly
there'll be technologies which are often
being championed by
tech investors like jeff bezos the
founder of amazon
technologies of surveillance which are
designed to make sure that we do our job
and to evaluate us and measure us so
i i don't think of that in futuristic
terms it's it's already arrived the
really interesting question is when it
begins to affect
um the higher-end workers and i use that
term carefully i'm not sure we're so
high-end but whether it's commentators
like you or i
whether it's lawyers or doctors or
engineers or politicians
but we're in the midst of this
revolution and it's a very profound one
in terms of the workplace so for example
there's a big debate as you know about
whether or not people should go back to
the workplace and the office which is an
interesting debate and it doesn't affect
me because i've always worked from home
but a lot of people it does affect
and they think well they have more
freedom at home more independence but
actually they don't with all this new
technology observing people's work it
doesn't mean just a camera but it's
smart tech which can determine whether
or not we're actually working or
doing something else so all this
technology is designed to measure our
performance
in the workplace and perhaps elsewhere
and it's already arrived we're in the
midst of this revolution it's a very
profound one it's probably
the most profound one of the 21st
century so that's why um
you know this question of whether ai
rules is scientific and headline
grabbing but actually kind of
uninteresting the really interesting
question is
the tech of ai which is much more
mundane and down to earth but actually
changing the world as we speak
so
are you talking the tech are you
referring to things like ai that's able
to answer
well that's different that's ai that's
used
for
medicine
uh so there's lots of ais that help
engineers and doctors and journalists i
mean there's ai
for me as a writer i mean it's very
basic um ai but it helps me spell
um
so that's a different issue what we're
talking about ai in the workplace it's
ai that evaluates our performance so it
goes the other way ai can be very useful
too i mean there's no doubt about that
no one would argue against ai that can
help fix cancer
but it goes both ways i mean the thing
where they are is it's so ubiquitous
it's like me saying you know are you for
or against oxygen
or are you for against the internet
clearly there are arguments for and
against but it's so ubiquitous and
essential that it's very easy to make
arguments for or against
do you think there's any way going
forward that the government or somebody
i don't know who could implement
policies to stop some of the negatives
people are concerned about about ai in
the workplace
yeah there will be but remember the
american government uh you're a canadian
immigrant um
the american government is profoundly
dysfunctional it has one of the the
least effective governments in the world
the uh staffed by in
incompetent people because smart
americans don't go into government it's
badly paid and frowned upon in our in
our social
hierarchies and culture
so the american government won't be the
government that addresses this in the
same way as the american government
hasn't been the government that
addresses
the dangers of big tech companies this
will likely be done in two ways by two
kinds of government
by the
sort of
authoritarian technocracy in china
where
they will just announce
regulation and legislation of ai
according to sort of some wise man
precept
chinese culture which has been inherited
now by the chinese communist party and
then by the the democracies of northern
europe the german government the
scandinavian government and the eu
government which i think will do a
reasonably good job uh american
government is always second or third in
this so eventually as these threats are
regulated and legislated against
so the american government will will
pick it up
they've done that with big tech they're
only beginning to address the dangers of
big tech now after the europeans and the
chinese have addressed it